now
[Music]
[Applause]
breaking news right now detectives are
on the scene of a shooting happen in the
northwest valley yeah brian it happened
near oso blanco and
grand teton and that's where we find 8
news now reporter sasha loftis there
live with the latest
[Music]
denise and brian you can see this is a
pretty quiet neighborhood here in the
far
northwest valley the scene happening
right behind me still a pretty active
situation
see multiple metro police cars here
along
where this happened along this road
again in this quiet neighborhood now
this is all preliminary we're told
detectives are still on the way to the
scene but what we know
so far is that one person was taken to
the hospital with multiple gunshot
wounds shot multiple times
as of now there are no suspects in
custody again detectives are in route so
this is still the very beginning of this
investigation no update on that victim's
condition
exactly how that person is doing but
again one person taken to the hospital
with multiple gunshot wounds shot
multiple times here in this neighborhood
off of osoblanca and grand teton in the
far
northwest valley off of the u.s 95 so of
course stay with eight news now for the
very latest you can see
daffodil sun the main road where this
happened is blocked off but otherwise
you can drive through this neighborhood
no major roads are closed at the moment
but again
stay with 8 news now both on air and
online for the very latest as this
situation continues to develop
for now reporting live in the northwest
valley sasha loftis 8 news now